I think the question
and I'll tell you why I don't think we
have a right to talk about evil people
if we could see the inside of people's
souls we might have a right to do that
but if anybody can do that it's God and
on some accounts even God doesn't know
how people are going to act and
certainly on Kant's account and on
Freud's account we don't know our own
souls very well we're subject to
self-deception we tell ourselves that
we're doing things for all kinds of
reasons that aren't true so talking
about evil people I think completely
misses the mark where an awful lot of
progressives go wrong is that they see
that they see that things are
complicated and then they say well we
can't talk about evil at all I think on
the country we can as long as we talk
about evil actions and I think it's not
hard to come up with a whole list of
evil actions and I think pointing it to
the Nazis is too easy I think they're a
whole bunch of other evil actions that
we can point to we have to realize that
they can be committed by people who not
only may not have evil intentions but
sometimes have good ones and certainly
very often have mediocre ones